c'est à l'aide de milliers de poissons
tropicaux comme ceux ci qu'une équipe du
chum a découvert un nouveau traitement
médical qui pourrait selon u ralentir la
progression de la sclérose latérale
amyotrophique
l'un c'est là le gros problème parce que
le niveau génétique c'est bien avancé en
double creux beaucoup de jeunes qui dans
la salle à mais en même temps pas
beaucoup de médicaments
il y a 6 ans et deux chercheurs ont
l'idée de greffer des gènes de la sl aa2
animaux de laboratoire le poisson zèbre
et le minuscule versé élégance
puis ils ont exposé leurs cobayes à
toute une panoplie de médicaments on a
testé des médicaments connus qui ont
utilisé pour traiter d'autres maladies
avec l'idée que si on pourra trouver une
molécule avec un effet su rester là ce
pour beaucoup plus facile de l'utiliser
chez des patients au total il teste 3800
produit avant de trouver le bon le pim
aux ide un antipsychotique résultats
exposés aux pies moses les muscles
paralysé des poissons zèbre retrouve
rapidement leur mobilité
même chose pour les verts l'ont le plus
démontré qu'il y avait des connexions
entre les neurones de la moelle épinière
les muscles qui étaient défectueuses et
qu'on pouvait maintenir en présentant
des médicaments testés sur 25
volontaires en 2015
le pi moisi de passe le premier test
avec succès des résultats encourageants
pour daniel rompre et atteint de la s
est là depuis 2016
c'est quelque chose parce que je
pourrais comprendre le restant de
nouveau mais ça au moins ça possiblement
s'arrêtera la progression il espère
maintenant être parmi la centaine de
patients sélectionnés pour le nouvel
essai clinique qui débutera bientôt dans
9 centres hospitaliers canadien quand on
fait de nous mêmes
on peut nous protéger n'importe quoi on
connaîtra les résultats de ce nouvel
essai clinique d'ici deux ans s'il est
concluant on pourra offrir le président
rapidement et à peu de frais aux
patients atteints de la sla ici normal
grondin radio canada montréal